TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
>> Tucker: WELCOME TO TUCKER
AGO TODAY THAT BUZZ FEED
NOW A YEAR LATER THEY ARE BEING
SUED FOR DEFAMATION BY THE
BUZZ FEED NEWS WILL JOIN US
LATER IN THE SHOW TO DEFEND HIS
BUT FIRST TONIGHT, PRESIDENT
TRUMP SUGGESTED YESTERDAY THAT
HE'S WILLING TO SIGN ANY DEAL ON
DACA THAT CONGRESS IS ABLE TO
HAMMER OUT.
A DEAL DOES SEEM A LONG WAY OFF,
BUT MAYBE GETTING CLOSER TODAY
HOUSE REPUBLICANS OUTLINED A
BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW DACA
AMNESTY FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
IS CRUCIAL TO THEIR OWN
ABROAD.
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN FROM
TEXAS REPRESENTS THE BORDER CITY
NOMINATION TO CHALLENGE SENATOR
TED CRUZ THIS FALL.
HE SPONSORED LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD PROVIDE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
FIGHT DEPORTATION.
CONGRESSMAN THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
AT HOME, IF YOU'RE A VOTER
WATCHING THIS DEBATE, YOU HAVE
THE REPUBLICANS CONCEDING THAT
DACA RECIPIENTS CAN STAY IN THE
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH.
OVER ALSO.
SO CAN YOU UNDERSTAND HOW SOME
PEOPLE WATCHING THAT MIGHT
CONCLUDE THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
SPENDING MORE TIME AND ENERGY
WORRYING ABOUT PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY THAN AB AMERICAN
CITIZENS?
>> I GUESS I DON'T MAKE THE
CONNECTION, TUCKER.
I THINK THAT MOST AMERICANS,
MOST TEXANS, CERTAINLY THOSE
DREAMERS CAN CONTINUE TO REMAIN
AN THRIVE IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO IS A PH.D.
STUDENT IN MATH BIOLOGY AT TEXAS
TECH.
YOU HAVE ALONZO GUIREL WHO DIED
TRYING TO RESCUE FELLOW TEXANS
DURING THE FLOODING AFTER
HARVEY.
HE WAS A DREAMER.
AS REPUBLICAN AS IT GETS IN
JUST DEPORTED ONE OF THE HONOR
ROLL STUDENT.
STOP YOUR SPEECH.
THERE ARE A LOT OF GOOD DREAMERS
FOR SURE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF BAD ONES.
MILITARY.
THAT'S NOT AN INDICTMENT OF ALL
PEOPLE HERE UNDER DACA.
LET'S JUST GET REAL.
THEY'RE NOT ALL VALEDICTORIANS.
THE QUESTION IS THERE ARE A LOT
OF GOOD AMERICAN CITIZENS AS
WELL.
CAN YOU SEE WHY, WHEN DEMOCRATS
SAY, WE'RE NOT GOING TO FUND THE
GOVERNMENT UNLESS YOU ALLOW
THESE PEOPLE TO VOTE AND BRING
THEIR RELATIVES WITH THEM IS
MAYBE NOT IN SYNC WITH MOST
PEOPLE HERE.
>> I GUESS I DON'T SEE THAT.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IN EL PASO
TEXAS WHERE I AM RAISING MY KIDS
COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO THRIVE.
EVERY SINGLE YEAR FOR THE LAST
20 YEARS IS WE ARE A CITY OF
IMMIGRANTS INCLUDING DREAMERS
WHO CRIB TO OUR SUCCESS AND OUR
SAFETY.
THAT BENEFIT IS SPREAD OUT OVER
EVERYBODY IN MY COMMUNITY,
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF TEXAS
AND TO THIS COUNTRY.
SO IT'S VERY GOOD FOR AMERICA,
NOT JUST FOR DREAMERS, NOT JUST
FOR THEIR FAMILY.
>> Tucker: WAIT.
HOLD ON.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
I JUST CHECKED THE SCHOOL
NUMBERS IN EL PASO, THE CITY
YOU'RE BRAGGING ABOUT.
39%, ONLY 39% HAVE GRADUATED
RELATIVES FROM ABROAD.
WOULDN'T YOU THINK?
AGAIN, PRIORITIES.
>> I DON'T THINK WORKING ON
THESE THINGS IS MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE.
YOU'LL FINE NO ONE HAS WORKED
HARDER OR DONE MORE FOR EXAMPLE
FOR VETERANS IN THIS COUNTRY
WHEN IT COMES TO MENTAL CARE ACT
ACCESS.
THAT'S A VERY SACRED PRIORITY OF
MINE.
I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
PROGRESS WITH REPUBLICAN MEMBERS
ON THIS ISSUE.
AT THE SAME TIME, I CAN ADVOCATE
FOR THE SUCCESS OF OUR COMMUNE
AND OUR COUNTRY BY ENSURING THAT
THE DREAMERS STAY HERE.
THERE'S EXTRAORDINARY POSITIVE
ECONOMIC BENEFIT TO THOSE
DREAMERS STAYING HERE.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE NUMBERS ON
>> I ABSOLUTELY DO.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T ACTUALLY.
THIS HAS BEEN LOOKED AT A LOT.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT
BRINGING PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOWER
THAN AVERAGE EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT, AS THEY DO, INTO
THIS COUNTRY MAKE THE REST OF US
RICHER.
THERE'S JUST NOT EVIDENCE FOR
THAT.
>> ECONOMISTS HAVE LOOKED AT
THIS.
IT'S MEASURED NOT IN THE
MILLIONS BUT TENS OF BILLIONS OF
THAT'S GOOD FOR ALL OF US.
>> Tucker: LOT OF THESE AREN'T
MINORS.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
WHY IS IT GOOD FOR AMERICANS,
HERE ILLEGALLY?
YOU SNEAK IN TAXPAYERS PAY FOR
YOUR LAWYER, YOU SPONSOR
HOW DOES THAT BENEFIT AMERICANS
EXACTLY?
>> I THINK IT'S KEEPING TRUE TO
WHO WE ARE.
WHEN YOU HAVE ASYLUM SEEKERS
FROM SOME OF THE MOST VIE LEN
BRUTAL COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD
LIKE EL SALVADOR, WHO ARE YOUNG
KIDS OR YOUNG FAMILIES.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO APPLY
FOR ASYLUM IN THIS COUNTRY,
KNOWING THE LAW, HAVING AN
ADVOCATE AND AREN'T RETURNED TO
A COUNTRY WHERE THEY FACE IN
SOME CASES CERTAIN DEATH.
THEY DIDN'T COME AS REFUGEES
THROUGH ONE OF OUR MANY PROGRAMS
TO BRING REFUGEES HERE.
>> VERY OFTEN THEY CAME AS
ASYLUM SEEKERS WHO PRESENTED
THEMSELVES TO BORDER AGENTS.
>> Tucker: SO TAXPAYERS ARE
>> NOT TO FIGHT AMERICAN LAW.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> ACTUALLY, TO GET RIGHT TO
AMERICAN LAW.
TO MAKE SURE THEY SHOW UP TO
THEIR COWER HEARINGS.
AGAIN, THAT'S IN EVERYONE'S
>> Tucker: FOR US TO PAY FOR
LAWYER SO THEY CAN FIGHT
DEPORTATION.
HEALTHCARE BILL FORCE PEOPLE WHO
SNUCK IN HERE?
WHY DID YOU SPONSOR LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD HAVE ALLOWED THAT,
TOO?
>> IT'S GOOD FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN OUR COUNTRY, WHO ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO THIS COUNTRY'S
SUCCESS TO BE SAFE, TO BE
HEALTHY, TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO CONTRIBUTE.
>> Tucker: DID THE LAW SPECIFY,
DID YOUR BILL SPECIFY IT ON
APPLIED TO PEOPLE WHO WERE
BENEFITTING OUR COUNTRY?
I DON'T THINK IT DID.
I THINK IT WAS ANYBODY HERE
ILLEGALLY WOULD GET FREE HEALTH
CARE AT TAXPAYER EXPENSE.
I'M SORRY, WITH ALL RESPECT, I'M
CONFUSED BY WHY WE SHOULD PAY
FOR HEALTHCARE OF SOMEONE WHO
BROKE OUR LAW TO GET HERE?
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
>> YEAH, I DON'T THINK YOU'RE
READING THE BILL CORRECTLY.
>> Tucker: I THINK I AM.
>> I THINK YOU'RE LOSING SIGHT
OUR COMMUNITIES, OUR STATES AND
THAT ONLY PEOPLE CONTRIBUTING TO
OUR COUNTRY WOULD GET FREE
HEALTH CARE OR DID IT ALSO APPLY
TO GANG MEMBERS OR VAGRANTS.
I THINK THEY WERE COVERED TOO,
WEREN'T THEY?
IS GOING TO BE SICK, IF SOMEONE
NEEDS HELP, THAT WE DELIVER IT
IN THE MOST EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE
COST EFFECTIVE WAY POSSIBLE.
>> Tucker: COST TPBIVE TO PAY
FOR HEALTHCARE OF PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY?
>> Tucker: HOW ABOUT NOT PAYING
FOR IT AT ALL?
>> THEN YOU CAN WATCH PEOPLE DIE